president biden insisting the way he got
out of afghanistan was a extraordinary
success but the american people disagree
the commander-in-chief's poll numbers
nose diving after the chaotic exit from
kabul a new national poll out with this
headline quote biden's awful august
approval sinks on afghan pull out large
majority call afghan war a failure
43 percent of americans approve of the
job he's doing that's the lowest in that
poll since biden took office and as the
president looks to push past afghanistan
the media is ignoring a big development
the major networks largely avoiding
biden's phone call with then-afghan
president ghani where president biden
reportedly pressured the afghan leader
to say the taliban wasn't winning
all right guys it's friday but we've got
some dark topics to discuss um joey what
do you make of this uh and the president
calling this an extraordinary success
you know it's not about blaming biden
for the crisis we can talk about that
it's about being a leader you know
strong leaders make bad decisions every
good leader will make a bad decision
maybe a series of them but they lead
through it
and when as a leader president biden
cowers and he blames afghans and he
blames trump and he blames his own
generals he says the buck stops with me
i took the consensus decision you know
how you kind of pivot right out of that
you don't look like a strong leader you
yell your way into a victory speech you
just don't show the american people that
you truly understand the gravity that is
felt in this house that we call america
it's not just the fact that we pulled
out of afghanistan it's not just the
fact that we have a 20-year war that we
get to claim failure on it's the posture
you have a marine general sit there and
say the taliban we're our partners you
have the entire administration saying
one thing and almost doing another then
you've got about 22 million veterans
that sit back and look at that and go
wow were we betrayed what happened here
you have to understand the tone and
tenor of the men and women that fought
this war in order to end it and he
doesn't
and one thing that most politicians sean
do understand is poll numbers there are
a lot of bad ones today for the
president on a number of issues but
overall this seems to be dragging him
down we did see his poll numbers were
coming down with other worries about the
economy and other things before this um
chaotic withdrawal and the loss of 13
service members and others still
critically wounded yeah so i mean i
think what happens is you have a
situation where the media has basically
had his back right so whether it was the
border or covid or inflation the media
really hasn't reported those stories but
in a 20-year war in afghanistan where
we've spent so much blood and treasure
the media had to report the story and so
as we reported they see that this is an
utter failure from the president they
see 13 service members die they see
billions of dollars left in our
equipment and i think to joey's point
when you look at leadership you want
leaders to actually change course with
the facts on the ground so if you if
you're getting from the afghan president
that you have almost 15 000
international terrorists coming into the
country the taliban is surging they
would expect the president to change
course maybe keep bagram air base maybe
bring a few more troops in so we can get
americans out that's exactly right
that's that's the right approach that
any leader would have even donald trump
if you recall he wanted to get out of
afghanistan at the end of 2020 and
because the facts were changing on the
ground he kept pushing that date back
because he was a leader looking at facts
not at perception as joe biden wanted
the afghan government to do to to to
send a perception to the world as
opposed to the reality well there's been
a conversation jessica over the last
couple of weeks whether seeing how
terribly things were going the president
would change course that sean talks
about but reporting today from inside
the administration says he does surround
him with himself with people that have
differing viewpoints so they can
challenge him but that it's
exceptionally hard to change his mind
once he's decided this is the course
it's one of the advantages of getting
someone in office that you've known for
50 years they're consistent and joe
biden has been stubborn especially on
foreign policy
since he entered professional dc public
life
so it isn't surprising he is surrounded
by virtue of the fact that so many
members of the obama administration uh
were played an integral role obviously
in continuing this fight in afghanistan
i feel very passionately about that
worked with afghans who are still left
over there who helped us as translators
who fought alongside us and have been
quite outspoken whether they've deleted
those tweets that they put up or those
instagram posts i mean they're members
of the state department dod who've all
expressed displeasure at this and to
johnny joey's point i think there's
something really interesting in the
polling because there's that dichotomy
that too many politicians miss which is
that americans are smart enough to
understand how hard these issues are so
while his approval is sunk down into the
low 40s for the first time in his
presidency and i would add that that's
you know it doesn't make him a huge
outlier in presidential history you
still have 65 to 70 percent of americans
who think this was the right call so
they are smart enough to know the
difference between the right call and
how we did it and i think that's where
he's getting so much criticism from
democrats and certainly independents who
are saying yeah we're for this we don't
20 years is enough of this but let's
talk about who's left behind let's talk
about how quickly this happened we
didn't need to be out by september 11th
it's an incredibly important day in
american history but it's not the be all
and end all if people are scared of a
new terror attack or we have you know
potentially tens of thousands of people
who were promised a new life here in
america for helping us well and in the
way that you talk about that that gets
to sort of this headline with abc and
washington post their poll they head out
today uh it doesn't have a ton of great
news uh for the president and so good
morning america spent according to the
media research center 30 seconds on the
entire poll it's their poll and then the
washington post headline was american
support withdraw not the way it was done
so again it gets back to that
conversation that we know most people
are ready to go
but that's how they're framing these
negative numbers for the president uh
they are framing up so the the polls to
your point the polls are a call to
action for the media that they got to
jump in and help joe biden beca they're
going to ignore the stories that need to
be covered and like don lemon and chris
hayes they're going to start trying to
rewrite history
now
these grifters pawned off this defective
human h-bomb to the american people and
more and more we want to give him back
the uh they're act they actively and and
sometimes unethically got joe biden
elected remember the hunter biden laptop
and the 50 senior intelligence officers
who said that it was russian
disinformation do they still have jobs
because maybe their employers ought to
rethink that this country right now
looks like an exploding septic tank
and these media con artists
this is what they said would happen
under a
second term for president trump
the
it goes to the point and i
say this over and over again
policy is more important than
personality that a flawed person with
good policies has a much better impact
on the nation
and jessica you said joe biden was
consistent i would say consistently
terrible when it came to foreign policy
again he was against the raid that took
out osama bin laden and
he stands up over and over and over
again and lies to the american people so
please
do not spit in our faces and tell us
it's raining he was using we know better
bro yeah he was and the mission
the surge was the single most effective
thing we did in the entire 20-year war
we have pushed the taliban out of
afghanistan twice we did it in 2001 we
did again in 2009 10 11 10 when i was
there 11 when we had the most troops
there the deadliest time in the war he
was he was vice president for eight
years of this war and you want to stand
there and tell me you inherited you're
probably the only president that did not
inherit this war because you were in
charge of a large portion of it as the
number two in command for eight years of
it you could at least argue george w
bush got handed a raw deal from uh from
his predecessor who had a chance to to
kill bin laden multiple times but julian
i were talking with us before the show
and we i supported the withdrawal i
supported trump saying let's bring our
troops home but what does that mean
right does that mean bringing every
single last troop home or could have we
had still some presence in bagram could
we still offered air support to the
afghani troops to push back the taliban
we didn't have any joey jones guys on
the ground fighting the taliban but we
could have had a presence that could
have helped us secure afghanistan make
sure the taliban doesn't take over and
we don't have the afghanistan but that's
as a platform to grow terrorists that's
been there to move around the world
that's been the mission since 2014. it
was a counter-terrorism operation but we
have lost we have no cia listing posts
we have nobody on the ground gathering
intelligence that's part of the problem
well now we've blown up partnerships
with people who may have trusted us to
feed us information well and maybe why
should they and we've blown up our
relationship with britain and germany
and france and we it is but these are
the adults in the room these are going
to be the the ones that get respect
around the world right when joe biden
came into office oh contraire as we were
told